veamos si puedo tomar esta expresión
cuadrática de aquí es decir x cuadrada
más 16 x 9 y escribirla de esta forma y
tal vez estás pensando hey sal porque
debería de preocuparme por esto y bueno
una de las razones es porque ser capaz
de manipular cosas como estas y pasarlas
a este tipo de formas es muy buena
práctica algebraica pero como veremos en
el futuro lo más importante de todo esto
es que esta técnica se llama completando
el cuadrado y es una técnica muy valiosa
para resolver ecuaciones cuadráticas y
de hecho es la base de la prueba de la
fórmula cuadrática la cual aprenderás en
un futuro pero no con más ansias mejor
primero vamos a resolver este ejercicio
vamos a trabajar con esta técnica muy
interesante entonces como escribimos
esto
de esta forma bueno una manera de ver
esto es que si expandimos esta parte que
tenemos aquí que me quedaría me quedaría
cuadrada x cuadrada más dos veces el
primero por el segundo dos veces x por
am que es lo mismo que a x más el
cuadrado del segundo que en este caso es
a entonces me quedaría más cuadrada y
claro no olvidemos esta vez más b
entonces vamos a tomar esta expresión
que tengo aquí la voy a escribir de
nuevo pero esta vez la voy a escribir
con un pequeño espacio adentro de ella
me voy a tomar x cuadrada x cuadrada más
16 x 16 x y por acá voy a poner al 9
espacio
9 y ahora quiero que observes lo
siguiente primero tenemos aquí esta x
cuadrada que también la tenemos aquí
aquí tenemos una x cuadrada pero después
tenemos aquí uno más 16 x y aquí tenemos
12 x entonces si queremos que 2a x sea
lo mismo que 16 x
eso quiere decir que cuanto tiene que
ser a déjame ponerlo aquí aquí voy a
poner 2 a x2 x x y bueno eso significa
que entonces 2 a tienes que ser 16 o
dicho de otra manera am tiene que ser 8
tiene que ser 8 entonces si quiero tener
aquí una cuadrada aquí quiero tener una
cuadrada y a vale 8 entonces aquí tengo
que sumar el cuadrado de 8 que es 64 64
pero ten cuidado no puedes agregar
números de la nada en una expresión sin
cambiar el valor de la expresión
entonces si no quieres cambiar el valor
total de esta expresión lo que
necesitamos hacer es restar 64 y restar
64 entonces no está todo lo que he hecho
ahorita fue simplemente tomar nuestra
expresión original y le sume 64
y leer este 64 por lo tanto no estoy
cambiando el valor de la expresión pero
lo valioso de todo esto es que ahora
esta primera parte encaja muy bien con
el patrón del cuadrado perfecto que
tenemos a la derecha encaja muy bien
justo con este patrón que tengo aquí con
este patrón que tengo aquí tenemos x
cuadrada más dos veces a x en este caso
recuerda que a vale 8 y entonces a
cuadrada vale 64 y si te preguntas cómo
obtuve es de 64 entonces recuerda lo
siguiente tome el 16 lo divide a la
mitad y lo eleve al cuadrado así
llegamos al 64 entonces lo que puse
adentro de este rectángulo morado será
déjame ponerlo aquí va a ser lo mismo
que x
8 esto elevado al cuadrado y una vez más
sabemos que es esto porque sabemos que a
vale 8 entonces aquí me queda x 8
elevado al cuadrado y luego viene todo
esto que está a la derecha todo esto que
tengo aquí y bueno cuánto es
9 - 64 piénsalo así 64 menos 9 55
entonces esto de aquí será lo mismo que
menos 55 y hemos terminado escribimos
esta expresión de esta forma lo que se
conoce como completando el cuadrado